The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
Where were we,
last time?
Last time, we said we were
setting aside the problem of the
structure of the atom.
We were setting it aside
because we were stuck,
and what we had to do was to
look at another area of
discussion.
And that is this wave-particle
duality of light and matter,
because it is that discussion
that is going to give us the
clues about how to proceed.
We are putting aside the
discussion of the structure of
the atom all the way until next
Wednesday, because next Monday,
I was reminded,
is a student holiday.
[APPLAUSE]
And so we started.
We talked about the wave-like
properties of light.
We said that the property of
superposition,
the fact that you can put waves
at the same point in space and
their amplitudes add.
Since waves have both positive
and negative amplitude,
that means that you have
constructive and destructive
interference.
And it is those interference
phenomena, then,
that are evidence for wave-like
property.
And we did the two-slit
experiment to try to give you an
example of interference
phenomena.
We were trying to understand
those interference phenomena,
and did so in terms of this
diagram here.
The interference phenomena that
we saw was an array,
actually a row of bright spots,
dark spots, bright spots,
dark spots.
And we drew these semicircles
here around each one of the
slits.
They represent a little bit of
the wave that emanated through
those slits.
Because those slits are small,
then, those waves emanated
equally in all directions.
That is why these semicircles
represent the wave maxima.
And what we discovered is that
if we looked along this line
here, this line which led to
this bright spot,
that all of the waves along
this line were constructively
interfering.
That is, we had the maximum of
the two waves at the same point
in space, or the minimum of the
two waves at the same point in
space.
And we noticed that everywhere
along this line,
where we had that constructive
interference,
the difference in the distance
of the waves traveled was one
lambda.
We noticed, here,
that everywhere along this line
that led to a very bright spot,
we had constructive
interference.
And the difference in distance
traveled by those two waves was
two lambda.
And, likewise,
up here, along this line,
the difference in the distance
traveled was zero lambda.
And from just that,
in a sense, qualitative
observation, we drew a
conclusion.
And that conclusion was in
order to get maximum
constructive interference,
a condition that had obtain,
is that the difference in the
distance traveled by the two
waves has to be an integral
multiple of the wavelength.
N could be 0,
1, 2, 3, etc.
And so, the very bright spot
here that always bisects the two
slits, since N is 0,
we call that the zero-order
interference feature,
or the zero-order fraction
feature.
The bright spot that is either
to the left or to the right or
up or down of that center bright
spot is the first-order
diffraction feature or the
first-order interference
feature.
And then the second bright spot
up or down from the center is a
second-order diffraction
feature.
And so on and so on.
And in recitation section,
what you also should have done,
is you should have reasoned
through what the condition was
for destructive interference.
That is in between these bright
spots, you have dark spots as a
result of destructive
interference.
And that results because,
say, right here you get a dark
spot --
Right here at that point you
would see the maximum of one
wave at the same point in space
as the minimum of the other,
and so they exactly cancel.
And so by just analyzing what
waves were destructively
interfering, you should have
come up with a general
expression for destructive
interference,
of N plus one-half,
that quanity,
times lambda.
That is your general condition
for destructive interference,
the difference in the distance
traveled by the two waves.
This kind of diagram here we
are also going to see on Friday,
because this interference
phenomenon is the property
associated with waves.
And what we are going to do is
see this diagram again when we
scatter electrons for particles.
We are going to see that
particles, also,
will destructively and
constructively interfere.
They also have wave-like
properties.
That is what we will do on
Friday.
We have established,
now, the wave-like properties
of radiation,
so I would like to move on and
talk about the evidence for the
particle-like nature of
radiation.
The evidence for the
particle-like nature of
radiation comes from an effect
called the photoelectric effect.
Shortly after Thompson
discovered the electron,
scientists were noticing that
if you took a metal and shined
radiation on that metal,
that indeed electrons were
emitted.
Electrons came off.
These were called
photoelectrons.
However, the radiation that you
shined on the metal had to have
a frequency nu that was greater
than or equal to some threshold
frequency, nu nought.
That is, if you took radiation
of some frequency here,
nu, that was less than this
threshold frequency,
well, you did not get any
electrons off.
Well, another way to kind of
understand that data or that
effect is to just plot the
number of the electrons that
come off as a function of the
frequency of the radiation.
And so at low frequency,
there are no electrons,
but all of a sudden you get to
nu nought, and then electrons
start coming off.
And no matter how high you
increase the frequency here,
the number of electrons that
come off remains the same,
remains constant.
And it turned out that for the
metals that were looked at,
at that time,
the threshold frequency,
here, was in the UV range of
the electromagnetic spectrum.
Well, in addition to just
measuring the number of
electrons and generally
observing this effect,
scientists did not understand
what was going on.
So they just started measuring
everything they could think
about measuring.
And one quantity that they
measured was the kinetic energy
of these electrons that were
being emitted.
And so you take kinetic energy
here, KE, as a function of the
frequency.
They found that at low
frequency, again,
there is no kinetic energy,
because there are no electrons.
And then at some frequency,
all of a sudden electrons
started coming off.
And the kinetic energy of those
electrons seemed to increase
with the frequency once past
that threshold frequency,
nu nought.
Well, this was really another
one of these conundrums,
here, at that time,
because classical physics,
classical electromagnetism,
classical physics had no way of
explaining these data.
And, in fact,
what classical physics
predicted is that the kinetic
energy of these electrons,
that that kinetic energy should
have nothing to do with the
frequency of the light.
That is, the kinetic energy was
constant.
As you increased the frequency
of the light,
classical physics would tell
you that the kinetic energy
should not be affected by the
frequency of the light.
There was nothing in the
classical way of thinking,
classical electromagnetism that
connected the frequency of the
light to the kind of energy,
to the kinetic energy.
There was no way for blue light
to make the electrons have a
larger kinetic energy,
and for blue light to have an
effect on the kinetic energy,
and red light to not have an
effect on the kinetic energy.
In addition,
what classical physics
predicted is that the kinetic
energy of the electrons should
be dependent on the intensity of
the light.
That is, the more and more
intense the radiation on the
metal, the more and more kinetic
energy those electrons should
have.
Because, after all,
if you increase the intensity
of the light going into the
metal, you are putting more and
more energy into it.
That should be reflected in
just how energetic those
electrons were picked out.
The more energy in,
the electrons ought to come out
with larger and larger kinetic
energy.
Of course, the observation was
that the kinetic energy of the
electrons had nothing to do with
the intensity of light.
The kinetic energy of the
electrons did not increase as
you made the light brighter and
brighter.
As you put more and more energy
in, the kinetic energy remained
the same.
It didn't have an effect.
This was a real conundrum here.
The known classical physics was
making predictions really just
contrary to what was being
observed.
These data, here,
of the kinetic energy versus
the frequency,
were around for a few years
before Einstein took a look at
them in 1905,
a hundred years ago.
And he looked at these data for
many different metals.
Here is some data for metal A,
for example,
and here is some data for metal
B.
And, in both cases,
it certainly looked like the
kinetic energy was linearly
dependent on the frequency of
the radiation.
But what was different for the
two different metals was the
threshold frequency here,
nu nought.
What Einstein did was,
he went and fitted a straight
line to these data,
y equals mx plus b.
And when he did that,
and he went to calculate the
slope here, m,
of these lines,
he thought "very interesting."
Because the slope of those
lines was 6.626x10^-34 joule
seconds.
The slope of those lines was
something called Planck's
constant, h.
You say so what?
Well, the reason he was so
interested in this is because
just a few years earlier,
there was a scientist by the
name of Max Planck who was
interested in understanding what
was called the black-body
radiation data.
What is a black-body?
Well, let's just,
for simplicity purposes,
think of the black-body as the
burner on an electric stove.
What you know is that if you
turn up the voltage on that
burner, the burner gets hot.
It increased in temperature.
And you increase the
temperature, and sooner or
later, that burner is glowing
bright red.
And you increase the
temperature some more,
and the burner is glowing a
brighter red.
And you increase it some more,
and it is glowing orange.
which you shouldn't do,
and it's glowing yellow.
And then if you could increase
it some more,
it's glowing white.
What is happening,
as you increase the
temperature, is that the
radiation from that black-body,
this is the black-body
radiation, is increasing in
intensity.
But, more importantly,
the frequency is getting larger
and larger.
Dark red, bright red,
orange, yellow,
white, those are all
frequencies.
The frequency is shifting to
higher and higher values.
And what was actually done at
that time is that the intensity
of that black-body radiation,
oh, and this material is not in
your notes, because you are not
responsible for it.
I am just trying to make this
surprise that Einstein noticed
about the slope.
I am just trying to put it in
some context,
why he was so surprised and
amazed at it.
This black-body intensity here,
people had dispersed that
radiation and looked at the
frequencies that were coming
off.
This is intensity versus
frequency.
Here is a general shape of that
intensity versus frequency.
That was observed for some
temperature T one.
That was a low temperature.
And then, when the temperature
was increased and the intensity
versus frequency was observed,
well, the frequencies generally
got higher.
This is higher temperature.
Intensity goes up.
And you increase the
temperature some more,
and you get even higher
frequency.
T three is the highest
temperature.
And that is what the data were.
What Planck was trying to do
was to understand the origin of
that black-body radiation.
What he said was that in these
black-bodies,
in these materials,
what there must be are
oscillators that are giving off
this radiation.
But he had another little kick
to these oscillators.
These oscillators were giving
off radiation or energy in
chunks, in quanta,
in particles.
And using that idea,
plus some statistical
mechanics, he was able to
calculate the shapes of these
curves.
That is, he indeed got,
for the lowest temperature
here, a curve that looked like
this.
And for T two,
he got a curve that looked like
this.
And for T three,
he got a curve that looked like
this.
He got the shape right,
but he wanted to get the
intensity right,
too.
What he realized he had to do
was he essentially needed to
have a scaling factor,
actually, in front of his
frequencies of his oscillators.
He wanted a constant.
And so he said,
what constant do I have to have
in order to make all of these
data fit the observation?
That constant is Planck's
constant, his own 6.626x10^-34
joule seconds.
There it is.
That is Planck's constant.
That is it.
There is nothing deeper here.
It is a natural constant.
It comes from our observations
of the world,
of nature.
That is it.
It is a fitting constant.
And so that is why Einstein was
so amazed, here,
when he realized this number is
the same as what comes out of
here.
There must be something very
fundamental about this h,
this Planck's constant.
That is the story.
Isn't that amazing?
What Einstein then proceeded to
do, of course,
is to write down the equation
of the straight line that he
just put through these data.
And so that equation is the
kinetic energy equal to nu,
which is our x,
h, which is the slope.
And then what he found was that
the intercept here,
of course, is minus h times nu
nought.
This is plus minus h times nu
And that is the equation of a
straight line.
Of course, he realized,
if this is energy on this side,
boy, there better be energy on
this side.
And so this h times nu
better be an energy.
And since this nu was the
frequency of the incident
radiation, therefore,
h times nu better be the energy
of the incident radiation,
E sub i.
That is where this expression,
energy equals h times nu
comes from.
Nothing more.
That is where it comes from,
the photoelectric effect.
This was the first time that
there was any relationship
between the frequency of the
radiation and the energy of the
radiation.
In classical electromagnetism,
there is no relationship
between the frequency and the
energy.
This was the first time in
which that relationship was
observed.
And what this is saying is the
following.
This is saying that you can
have any frequency of radiation
you want, but the corresponding
energy comes in these chunks of
h times nu.
h is a quantization constant.
Radiation, nu,
is continuous,
but the energy that corresponds
to any given frequency of
radiation is h times nu.
This E equals h times nu,
here, is thought of as a
quantum of energy.
A particle of energy.
A chunk of energy.
Later on, it became the photon,
the energy of a photon.
If this h times nu here
was an energy,
well, this h times nu nought
also better be an  energy.
It is the threshold energy.
Let's draw an energy level
diagram to try to understand
that.
I am going to plot an energy
here.
Let's draw an energy level for
an electron.
This is an electron,
here, bound to the metal.
And we know that it takes some
energy to rip this electron off
of the metal.
Up here, at higher energy,
is going to be our free
electron.
I will just call it
electron-free,
not bound to the metal anymore.
And the energy that is required
to pull the electron off,
from the bound state to its
free state, is this threshold
energy, h times nu nought.
This threshold energy is like
an ionization potential.
You know what the ionization
potential is.
Just the energy required to
pull an electron off an atom or
a molecule.
However, when we are pulling an
electron off a chunk of a metal,
we actually have another name
for it.
It is called the work function.
That is just historical,
but it is the same thing as an
ionization potential.
And we often give it the symbol
phi.
That threshold energy,
ionization energy for a metal,
is the work function,
here, h times nu,
phi.
The important point here is
this.
In order to get an electron off
of the metal,
what you have to have is
energy, E sub i.
That energy E sub i has to be
equal to at least the threshold
energy, h times nu nought.
If you come in with energy of
this radiation,
of this wavelength and that
frequency, you pulled the
electron off,
and then the electron is off
the metal and it just kind of
stays there.
It doesn't move away.
But you can also come in with
energy here, E sub i,
that is greater than this work
function, than the threshold
energy.
And you can pull the electron
off.
But then, the electron is
actually going to move away from
the metal, and the energy with
which it moves away from the
metal, its kinetic energy,
is just the incident energy
minus this threshold energy.
It is the excess energy here.
And I am going to write it as
the kinetic energy.
From that energy level diagram,
this energy,
the incident energy,
has to be equal to the work
function, h nu nought,
plus the kinetic energy.
Or, if I turned this around,
the kinetic energy is equal to
the incident energy minus h nu
nought.
The actual expression for the
energy that Einstein found,
I just turned that equation
around.
This is an equation that you
have to know.
I will not give this to you on
an exam.
Now, you don't have to memorize
it.
You just have to reason it.
Draw yourself an energy
diagram.
You know conservation of
energy.
The sum of these two energies
has to equal the incident
energy.
Then you will be all set.
Now, what is very important
here is the following.
If I come in with radiation
that is, say,
a half of the threshold energy.
Suppose I come in with two
photons, where each photon is
one half h nu --
The bottom line is that you are
not going to get an electron
off.
Even though you are coming in
with two photons,
which together are going to
give you the threshold energy,
you won't get a photon off.
You have to come in with at
least the energy of the work
function.
A photon has to have at least
this energy to get an electron
off.
That is the particle-like
nature of radiation.
Energy comes in chunks,
in particles of energy,
in quanta of energy.
Likewise, if I came in here
with a photon that had twice the
energy of the work function or
the threshold energy,
I would still only get one
electron off.
I would not get two electrons
off, even though energetically
you would be able,
in principle,
to get two electrons off.
But you won't.
You will only get one electron
off.
Whenever you send a photon in,
if it has enough energy,
that is if its energy is equal
to or greater than the work
function, you will get an
electron off.
There is one electron for every
photon.
You never get two electrons for
every photon,
or you can never get one
electron for two photons that
are lower energy.
That is the particle quantum
nature of radiation.
That is important.
Yes?
What is the form of the photon?
What do you mean by form?
Oh, you want a picture of the
photon.
You're looking at them.
You cannot draw a picture of a
photon because you want to
relate it to something that is
within your classical
experience.
And you cannot do that.
It isn't a classical particle.
That is what you're working
with right here.
You are trying to use your
experiences, that are everyday
experiences, to explain
something that isn't within your
everyday experiences.
You don't have a frame or a
format to do that.
Yeah?
Yes.
If you have a constant flux of
photons onto the surface,
you will have a constant flux
of electrons.
Now, there is a probability.
It is not necessarily the case
that every photon gets in,
will eject electrons,
because there are other kinds
of competing processes.
Whatever the rate with which
the photons come in.
It depends on the flux of the
photons.
And we will have some problems
like that, where we are going to
assume that the probability of
the electron coming off is going
to be one, so one electron for
every photon.
But, in reality,
there are competing processes.
Are all electrons being
ejected?
Actually, some electrons.
Again, this goes to the
probability.
Some are actually kind of going
in, too, into deeper the metal.
Not the probability,
right.
The rate at which the electrons
come out with is dependent on
the intensity.
The more photons you send in,
the larger the number of
photons per second coming in,
electrons per second coming out.
This is a plot,
here, of the energy of the
electrons.
That's all right.
Other questions?
Yeah?
Eventually.
Yes.
Absolutely.
There are other problems that
will come in.
Usually, your light source
isn't so energetic that you
could possibly do that.
Now, also usually what happens
is that you've got your metal
grounded, so that as you lose
electrons, new electrons come in
and fill it up to the fermi
level.
And so you don't charge up your
sample.
In an experiment,
if you had your metal just not
grounded and you did shine some
radiation, what would happen is
the metal would start to charge
up.
Then, that would make it
difficult to get electrons off.
Yes?
Yes.
How strongly those electrons
are bound to the metal depends
on the electronic structure of
the metal.
And we are going to talk a
little bit about what determines
the strength of the interaction
for electrons on atoms and
molecules, but it is similar to
what it is for metals.
That is coming in a few days.
Yes?
Yes, there is.
Right.
You don't actually have to have
a metal.
You could do it.
There are usually higher
frequencies on insulators and
semiconductors,
right.
It is harder to see the effect,
but it can be done and has been
done.
Well, what I want to do right
now is to show you an experiment
we are going to do.
We are going to do a
photoelectron experiment.
And the experiment is this.
We have a device up here.
What we have is an aluminum
plate.
And that aluminum plate is
mounted on this blue metal rod.
And in the middle of this rod
is a needle on a pivot.
And this is a fairly
frictionless pivot.
This black ring,
here, is just a support
structure, an insulating support
structure.
What we are going to do is put
some excess charge on this
aluminum plate.
And that excess charge is going
to run down this metal rod and
then onto this needle.
And because that excess charge,
the electrons on the needle and
the electrons on the metal rod
are repulsive,
since this is rather
frictionless,
that needle is going to move
because of the repulsive
interactions between these
electrons.
What we're then going to do is
try to do the photoelectron
experiment.
We are going to take some UV
radiation and shine it on this
metal and drive the electrons
off.
And we should see,
then, the needle swing back to
its original position.
I need a couple of volunteers
in order to do this experiment
here.
Come on up.
All right.
Fantastic.
I think that is all right.
Good.
Okay.
One of you needs to be the
charger, and the other needs to
be the discharger.
Which one?
You want to discharge?
Discharge, okay.
You come over here.
And what you are going to do is
discharge the aluminum plate
after we get some excess charge
on it.
You are going to do it just by
holding it up to here.
You have to get it kind of
close because it is not a very
intense UV source.
Could you get the video cam on
the side or on the center to get
where we are putting it?
I guess we are putting it on
the side, right?
Okay.
There we go.
There is the device.
You are the charger.
What we are going to do,
to get the excess charge,
we are taking a piece of
natural fur.
We are going to rub it on this
Lucite rod.
You have to keep your fingers
on the yellow tape here.
And we are going to transfer
some of the natural oils here
onto this rod.
And there are plenty of
negative ions around here and
free electrons.
That oil likes those negative
charges, and so there are going
to be excess negative charges on
this Lucite rod.
And then you are going to come
over here and just touch the
edge of this and let the
electrons flow onto there.
Are you right-handed?
You have to rub that really,
really hard.
[LAUGHTER] Great.
Go over there.
Touch the end.
Cool.
Why don't you give it another
jolt here and we will really
move that needle over.
Okay.
Discharger.
We have to give it another
jolt.
That is okay.
You may have touched it with
something else and discharged it
a little bit.
No, that's okay.
You have to get the hang of
this, here.
You are doing fantastic.
Take it off.
That's what it is.
You are holding it on too long.
Okay, that is pretty good.
Put it in front there.
Get it a little bit closer.
Here comes the UV radiation.
We did it.
Try it again really hard.
Just touch it.
Take it off.
Do it again.
You need to do it again.
You've got to get it right
here.
Not too much,
not too little.
Okay.
It is doing it.
Discharge in front.
Electrons off.
Now we have to do a control
experiment.
That is, you have got to charge
it up again, but now,
when you put the light there,
what I am going to do is hold
up a Pyrex plate in between the
light and the metal.
It is going to block the
radiation, and it should not
discharge.
You need to get on there.
Fantastic.
There it goes.
Here is the plate.
Get it to a little bit lower.
Do a good discharge.
[APPLAUSE] Fantastic.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for being a good
sport.
That is the photoelectron
experiment.
Hey, it works.
Well, what I want to do now is
just spend a few minutes working
on a few problems.
I think these are pretty
straightforward,
but I just want to make sure
that everybody is on the same
page here in terms of being able
to do the homework.
Here is the first problem.
The first problem says,
how many photons?
And remember what we said a
photon was?
E equals h nu.
This is the number of joules.
Implied is the number of joules
per photon, although we don't
usually write this,
but that is what that is,
joules per photon.
You may want to write it as you
do these problems.
How many photons associated
with radiation of a wavelength
lambda equals one picometer,
which is 1.0x10^-12 meters,
how many of these do you need
in order to create,
say, a laser pulse of energy
that is one joule?
Lasers are pulsed,
so I am talking about a pulse
of energy, one joule.
You want to draw yourself a
picture, here.
We are drawing a picture of one
pulse of energy,
one joule.
Now, we have not been given the
frequency, here,
of this radiation,
but we know the wavelength,
and we know the relationship
between frequency and
wavelength.
It is just c over lambda.
I know what lambda is.
I can calculate nu.
And, when I do that,
I find that the energy of the
photon, hc over lambda,
that energy of the
photon is 1.99x10^-13 joules per
photon.
And I am using one more figure
than is significant since this
an intermediate step in the
calculation.
If I want a pulse of one joule
of energy and I am asked how
many photons do I need to get
that, and each photon is
1.99x10^-13 joules,
well, that means that I am
going to need 5.0x10^12 photons.
There was a question here?
All right.
Let's work another one.
Here, we want to define what we
mean by power.
This says the power of
radiation from the continuous
laser is three milliwatts.
We have some laser,
and the power of that radiation
coming out is three milliwatts.
Well, what is power?
Power is energy per unit time.
It is the energy delivered or
the energy expended per unit
time.
The unit of power that we are
going to use is a watt.
A watt is a joule per second.
We are told that we have
radiation of three milliwatts.
That is 3.0x10^-3 joules per
second.
And the question asks,
how long will it take for a
total energy of one joule to be
supplied?
Well, one joule.
And we have the rate of energy
supply as 3x10^-3 joules per
second.
That gives us 330 seconds.
That is straightforward.
Finally, we have one more.
It says, how many photons per
second of, again,
the same radiation,
of the wavelength of one
picometer.
That means, again,
we are dealing with photons
that have an energy of
1.99x10^-13 joules per photon.
How many photons per second,
the rate of photons at the
wavelength do you have to have,
or do you have,
if the power of the radiation
is three milliwatts?
Well, the power of the
radiation is 3.0x10^-3 joules
per second, --
-- and we have 1.99x10^-13
joules per photon.
In order to have this kind of
power, what we have to have
being emitted is 1.5x10^10
photons per second.
All right.
The photoelectric effect is one
of the experiments that
demonstrated the particle-like
nature of light,
of radiation.
Particle-like nature because
you have to have these chunks of
energy to make some process
occur.
Next time, we are going to look
at and will just talk briefly
about the other experiments that
demonstrated the particle-like
nature of radiation.
And that other experiment is
the demonstration that a photon
has momentum,
even though it doesn't have any
mass.
See you Wednesday.
See you Friday.